Martha Stewart she's back she the woman
never goes away 71 years old she went on
the Today Show this week and she
announced that she's looking for a man
and where else would a robotic woman
find a man but the Internet let's take a
look we know what you're looking for in
a man all those issues what are you
looking for in a relationship are you
looking for a companion a partner
someone to do fun things with would you
consider marrying again depends and
that's okay I think not if not everyone
on online dating is looking for the same
kind of relationship and that's why it's
important to put in the profile who
you're looking for breakfast with
somebody I'd like to go to bed with
somebody you know that works we sleep
with somebody that's better to say I
think I think it'd be a very popular
online dater right so I love how
Martha's not sure where they're going to
bed with someone or sleeping with
someone is the one that has the sexual
context to it now I should mention the
guy she was sitting there with was her
nephew or her stepson or something who
of course is writing a book and she's
also writing a book is there no price on
anyone's head Martha Stewart has more
money than God and now she's putting
herself on match.com for a man but it's
really for a book right I mean of course
Adam first off at 71 she looks good I
did not know she was that old already
but uh she looks great and good for her
it's Martha Stewart she has this you
know a stereotype of being Martha
Stewart but it's so nice to see her
being like yeah I want to go to bed with
someone I'm a woman yeah I think that's
great I do yeah okay Martha I'm poking a
layer yeah no I'm not into the guilt
thing this but some are you know so look
it's a big part of me is again here we
go with the same topics like mass comm I
mean this must be a giant promotion that
they're doing trying to get the older
demographic on and she's probably
getting paid a boatload of money etc on
the other hand I think they're I'm sure
she's genuine about wanting to date
but in two things maybe I can find him
through this and and that was a nice
genuine moment where she was like eh I'd
like to go to bed with somebody and I
was like you go get him girl at 7:00 at
71 and look if I'm single like she is
and I'm past the age of 65 I've told
these guys uh it's no-holds-barred time
I mean like I will do anything I don't
give a damn what you think
cuz I'm agnostic I think once I die poof
lights out gone so you and the other
thing is like but what about your legacy
I Got News for you two hundred thousand
years from now no one has a legacy oh
okay okay so you better enjoy what what
you got on a building it will not be
there Martha Stewart joining match.com
does that sort of bring the internet
full circle because there used to be
this idea that if you were dating online
or you are hooking up or you were going
on Craigslist that it was bad and evil
anyone that but now Martha Stewart's on
The Today Show so has this thing really
just fully evolved at this point
officially now as of today it has anyone
it is all good if Martha Stewart's doing
it it's a-okay yeah if Jason Collins is
out then it must be okay to be gay in
sports and if Martha Stewart's not match
that it's officially sanctioned yeah and
it's true like I you know I've been
married for a while and we've been
dating for a while and stuff but I was
talking to a friend of mine who's
younger and she's like what stigma like
she doesn't even understand that there
was a stigma at some point she's like
what's obvious where where else would
you go I'm like a bar like it's so
weirdly inefficient why would you do
that she's like I put up my profile for
a certain period of time men flooded in
right and then I closed it down right
away so I don't have like two hundred
things to look through and then if I
ever want to date again I open it for a
brief period of time men flood in I'll
take you know however 1224 I'll sift
through find one or two to date and
that's how it works down welcome to
America yeah and this is one of these
things that's very different for
different sexualities because okay so
you're talking about a woman she can
open up this thing and there's a flood
of horny men that want a jumper
gay guys have Grindr you know you got a
straight guy has two
you know what you was screwed ironically
by not being screwed grinder is the
greatest app known to man yeah and I'm
so jealous of it we can't have a
straight grinder because women won't
participate there would be one very sore
woman surprise they do have the sphere
is iners and it's killing it is it oh
you think that's very successful I mean
people like to have sex I mean it's just
part of our DNA and girls are doing it
it's right my guys of course yeah I mean
it is very very successful you know but
society is changing so much so you're
probably right I mean you know I feel
like I'm like the old man now but I'm 43
right when I was growing up if you put
out a message like in my hometown of
East Brunswick New Jersey hey I'd like
to get laid yeah I mean hey man I like
you up these days people feel like they
can get to know someone a lot better
than meeting them in person when you
meet someone in person they can hide so
much people think there's sloughs now on
the internet and they think they can
figure out everything by going okay I'm
gonna see their page and see their
friends page and see it you know just
they know everything about them before
they even have to meet them yeah you
know what's switched this is like first
step of the matrix stuff you know I mean
where we just ultimately we're just
going to be batteries for this digital
life you're gonna have to have a tube in
your mouth to get some nutrition and
you're gonna be having sex in this
digital world and the whole thing yeah
you're not even actually gonna have the
sex you just press a button like I have
consented to have sex with you in this
theoretical world awesome yeah yeah all
right well that was kind of awkward lol
I want to remind you guys that the
official outfitter of the Reuben report
is bonobos go to bonobos com use code TR
r20 and get yourself this fancy shirt